your stock standard strategy for
approaching a question that you don't
really know what to do with yet is to
start from what you know and they just
do some work like like you're often
surprised by how much as you just start
to push on it it sat on some things
something's appear and now I can take
that to run with it it wasn't
immediately obvious but if I can see my
teeth in it to begin with it then we'll
maybe something will avenge so let's
have a look at this I know this right I
don't know this so I don't really want
to use that is like my basis to build up
I want to use that as where I am right
so here's where are many of you know
when I look at this the only thing
jumped out at me is to expand it's the
only thing that I can obviously see it
too so let's give a shot see what
happened I'm going to get due to pairing
up returns so it looks like you get for
a b-minus to a X you happy with that I
got take away to be x + + x squared
because of the double native yep happy
so that's that okay any suggestions now
what okay good I have the same guy on
both sides so let's just clean him off
so gone gone as i do that i can see
there's something else i can easily do
namely that all these coefficients are
to leave it right so i can just do mine
to you by too happy with that so I the 0
here and I've got to Amy take away next
take away be it okay not too bad
anything else you can see that I could
do from you I could potentially solve
for x I wanted to I could solve for x I
could get these X terms over here on the
left like so
and then what would I do I can factorize
good and you get okay yep is that ok now
I look at that everything I've written
is correct no problems for us as far as
I can tell ok the only problem with it
is it's gotten me nowhere in actually
proving this right so this is not true
but there's nothing that immediately
connects with this right so does anyone
have any suggestions for me it does ok
so a great way to go is if this is an AP
right and these are the terms I've got
none of these terms have appeared
anywhere here but I ought to expect that
they should somehow right that's exactly
right and they will in fact ok how I
probably say at least me when I looked
at this question the first time while
ago it didn't jump out at me at all you
can do something in one fell swoop but
it's not immediately obvious ok but we
will that's a great idea so I want to
give me that suggestion one on xpg am
one
ok so now I'm going to I in case you
didn't hear right out there rash
leadership anyway um suggestion was to
talk about the AMD arithmetic mean if
this is an AP right if it really is
anything then this should be the a.m of
this yeah that's true that's exactly
true my only problem with saying that is
I don't actually know that that's true
yet I trying to prove that what would
that look like one of X should be equal
to now how do I work out the arithmetic
mean of these two numbers i would add
them i'll take the average aight aight
so I'm going this Plus this and then I
divide by two that's taking the average
now you have a look at this how is that
connected to this ok sure you can see
here I bought whatever X but here i have
a point of contact right so if i take
the reciprocal the left on the right
like so i'm still not there yet but I've
got a promising sign I've got that to
their right that's good what am I gonna
have to do over here on the right that
is a fast way and is a long way ok maybe
suggest to you the quickest ways
remember we said oh this is really good
I've got a two there and I've got a two
there that's great what am I missing on
this numerator I'm missing a be attached
so clearly would be useful if I had an A
be here now if i'm going to multiply
this by a bee well then you better
multiply the denominator by David Wright
to a B once one on eight times a bee
once one on B times baby ok so I'm there
now I haven't proved it I've just mapped
out for myself a path right it wasn't it
me obvious where we go from here but now
that I see where I'm supposed to connect
to all right what would you like me to
do on the left hand side
so I could I can literally do this in
Reverse right so i can say excuse me
fine divide the top and bottom by AV
like that I just need member the two
there and then this turns into one of
our B and this sent into whatever a for
next step okay oh yeah that's right at
this point I was like oh I needed to fit
things over okay so I've got one over x
equals I might as well put these guys in
the right order that kinda finished now
i will say and this was not immediately
what I thought of doing it's fine it's
it amounts are directly to the same
thing however the am is kind of like a
it's a kind of proof it's a kind of
proof it's a lot our definition for what
an AP is we've got a definition for what
how to proven a piece in AP and we're
also got a definition of how to prove a
GPS of GP what's the definition why
can't I stop this into whether excited
here's that into where ok so i asked for
suggestions but this is the first
suggestion i got right so okay i'll come
to yours in a second I'll come to yours
in a second right I I don't know if
that's necessarily quicker though um
remember miss you are you going to give
me a definition we get a test or you
leave something else yeah how do I
good yeah t3 take my teacher right
should be equal to t to take away yeah
they go now by the way this ends up
being exactly the same as this because
seeing that is just like saying it's the
arithmetic mean let me demonstrate it
for you right oh excuse me see how
there's a minus one over here i'm going
to add it to both sides so that gives me
1 over B plus 1 over a there's a pesky
whatever X here that I might as well
collect my turns over here so that gives
me 2 over X does this look familiar
doesn't it like once I divide this two
by two there's my 1 over X and there's
my 1 over a plus whatever be on two it's
the same thing they're all saying the
same thing okay um different parts of
the mountain correct so I've kind of
assumed this definition in here which I
think it's I think it's better probably
it's more watertight to go with this
because that's literally the definition
of an AP service started with that
without first level we have that one and
then I
people who need to do anything on people
say and that one is already young people
said do I just say because they re cool
I wouldn't do it that way so everything
I put here in red and green it's kind of
like just by speaking space right it's
whatever is ordered to when this didn't
become like oh yeah I know what to do
right so I thought where else can I go
but what I would do is if I take this on
this is actually I think this is the
most watertight way of doing it is at
this point over here let me look is that
what I wanted yup
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'll say oh
ok now i know where i can take this
right i'm going to say okay i'm going to
divide everything through by a bx i'm
just going to write that they're from my
own say okay the reason why I know to do
that is because i'll get my over x over
a over B right it's kind of like the
reverse of doing the Lord's calm water
so this is going to have an the executor
cancer like that the beam the X are
going to cancel which gives me that and
then the beginner cancel which gives me
this what do you see that now stop stop
stop how did I think of it I need to
think of it because I've written this
before i knew it was going to go there
right and so i can see oh look there's
where the two is it should correspond to
that two over there where else I haven't
assumed anything on this bus line of
reasoning I assumed up if you assume
that it should get you discontent so I
shall I finish it
you hear that and now I just need to
rearrange turn to sorry 10 3 minus turn
2 equals term 2 minus term 1 i'm done
definition okay i prefer that because
it's it's the definition of an AP
therefore isn't anything but as you can
see like by all the lines of working in
different colors they all mathematically
amount to the same thing okay so i think
probably all of them would get a party
go take yeah